hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about cytopathic effects so
first what are cytopathic effects well
they are observable cell abnormalities
so basically ways in which the cells
become abnormal that we can observe
sometimes you need like a high-powered
microscope and special stains to observe
certain aside empathic effects sometimes
you can see them on a low powered
microscope it just depends on what kind
of cytopathic effect you're looking for
and what kind of cell type but so these
are actually caused by viral infections
and sometimes psychopathic effects are
called cpgs so let's talk about a few
different types now different viruses
infecting different cell types will
cause different kinds of cytopathic
effects but some of the ones that
doctors will be looking for is a change
in cellular shape especially cells it
should be flat becoming more rounded
also a loss of surface adherence so this
is when cells usually like they'd like
to grow attached to some kind of
substrate some kind of surface and if
they've been infected by a virus that
has basically mess these cells up
they'll stop adhering to a surface and
just start sort of floating in in the
medium
there's also shrinking of the nucleus so
the nucleus getting smaller another one
that they will look for is inclusion
bodies
so you may might never heard of this
before but inclusion bodies are
basically just aggregates of protein
that can collect in the nucleus or in
the cytoplasm basically wherever the
virus is dividing we're so the site of
viral replication you'll see these
aggregates of protein and that's what we
call inclusion bodies
another type of cpe is the formation of
multinucleated since the shell so since
this ax are when you have multiple cells
fuse together so you have one large sort
of overly large structure there's a lot
of different nuclei in it that came from
a lot of individual cells that are fused
together another possible CDE is
disruption of host cell chromatin so
when the host cell's DNA becomes
disrupted and that sort of disorganized
that's a type of CPE another one is cell
lysis remember that lysis simply needs
to first open a pop to tissue the first
open averse to part so cell lysis is
when a cell breaks open and this is cell
death that the cell dies might undergo
slices another type of CPE probably the
worst kind is transformation of the host
cell into an immortal cell immortal
cells are another name for cancer so
basically this is characterized by
something called loss of senescence
senescence senescence is the ability to
stop dividing and we obviously want
ourselves to
divide uncontrollably but when and
that's called senescence but when cells
lose senescence they can no longer stop
dividing they just start dividing
dividing dividing out of control
we call them immortal cells and this is
what leads to cancer as tumors now let's
talk about some examples of doctors
using psychopathic effects as a
diagnostic tool a really common one that
you've probably heard of is a pap smear
so once young women reach a certain age
it's recommended that they get a pap
smear every year and this is where a
doctor collects a sample from from the
woman's cervix so to get cervical cells
and those cervical cells are actually
viewed under a microscope and assessed
for different kinds of cees and they're
specifically looking for the CPEs that
are caused by HPV infection human
papilloma virus especially those that
would be indicative of cancer because
HPV is certainly well known for causing
cervical cancer so pap smears are
looking for these CPEs in order to
diagnose fat another way that CPAs can
be used diagnostically is with a
hepatitis C infection I have behind us C
infections and often be diagnosed based
on something called liver steatosis
this is basically the abnormal retention
of lipids in a cell so that's one of
these observable cell abnormalities that
can be linked back to a hepatitis C
infection if you're interested in
learning more about viruses check out my
video on introduction to viruses where
you can learn about viral replication
viral genomes different kinds of shapes
and structures and that is all for today
so thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time